that's why I'm a huge size hi I'm Jay
Van Buren my name is Donna Glaser
I'm Gina Brown my name is Denise I love
soul food because my mother and my
grandmother you have to pull though
history behind so for a little blues
little jazz gospel and so food comes out
with soul this is my food I was up
cooking this morning I have a six cheese
macaroni and cheese yes I do
and fried chicken now this chicken was
fried in peanut oil on the stove this
chicken was fried in the oven so it's
crispy and it's healthier for you than
the most people's fried chicken yeah
this is good I don't hold back on spice
I don't like bland food it's got a it's
gotta have a little bit of a kick I'll
be right back with you you have to have
that flavor and you can't be all over
the places so food it doesn't need any
rules and it just it's a basic taste
what helps makes mine better mine is
just better okay
yeah definitely sure mm-hmm
let me try it bring it on I am ready to
try other people's food I like other
people's food it's not it's not always
bad okay if I have to I mean but
nothing's going compared to this one but
I'm ready Oh dad this is tiny this is a
chicken leg or being a mini chicken look
this is little that's a nice one
he's just flaking I think it was brined
appropriately
this one's Doug this is this is great
and that's placed good as mine but it's
good
ya know that no no to the mac and cheese
the chicken was okay I'm not aware any
cheese now come one point five right
there that is some good chicken I mean
I'm not you know it's not I'm saying I
would rate this whole meal about a seven
seven and a half three I would give the
whole meal on three
[Music]
that's good the macaroni and cheese is
pretty good hmm she burnt the noodles I
don't know why y'all keep giving me a
soggy chicken that's my fried chicken
okay so you should never have that in
your chicken no one wants to eat that I
was like a feather on hearing something
else it wasn't clean properly you need a
chicken on this plate so chicken is far
better than the mac and cheese mac and
cheese is good but the chicken is really
nice it's not you know it it's not easy
to fried chicken you cannot serve this
to someone other than your family I'm
gonna go in because I'm brave and I have
health insurance but I'll give the whole
meal about a five I would send that back
there forever was an arrest in a
restaurant I would send it back I'm
gonna give it a nine just because
there's probably something that might be
better but this is really really good
Barry okay I would give it a one I'm
sorry
[Music]
this sort of looks like Velveeta cheese
but not bad at all after I would buy
this good cheese mac ratio good chicken
its flavor ball that's a little greasy
though my finger
chicken is not bad I wouldn't go to a
store to buy it I would make mine at
home but the chicken is not bad at all
could be a little she could have kept
the crunch I would tell you a secret
about keeping that crunch I'm not gonna
do that macaroni and cheese that's not
serving I don't know what that is and
it's not sticking together I mean look
at this I'll pass on that play this
chicken it's pretty good let's go for 1
to 10 I'd give it a 707 actually I give
an 8
[Music]
well they put cornmeal on fried chicken
oh do that no no sat here and waited so
long I'm hungry what is this but what is
this this is your best offer of a piece
of fried chicken I don't think I want to
try the chicken how old is this grease
this is not appropriate
Tessa shame that's fish chicken oh no
she cooked it in the fish grease oh
thanks oh I don't know I don't want to I
know I don't want to try it don't let me
ever see you do that again
what this here it's getting put in jail
for life coz this is murder don't eat
that that's a no-no you can't feed your
babies there come on
your babies everybody else's baby at the
barbecue a Mother's Day dinner no no no
no you beat and killed everybody in the
house paramedics want to enjoy mothers
see to don't cook
the maggot cheese isn't the best but the
chicken is all right
if you gotta make two batches there's
something wrong you know the whole play
get someone zero
double zero this carries a plate and I
did a nine I think on this plate this
carries it but don't do this again
you've been warned I forgot that I even
put bread crumbs in the flour I'm so
good happy Mother's Day
and I hope you know me and so that you
can have some of my my mac and cheese
have a good one
[Music]
you